hey folks welcome to another live stream
by myself Eric T and Eric s Anson how's
it going it's going alright how about
you good been playing some sniper ghost
Warrior 3 alright so you're gonna show
me your sniping skills so let's hop in
there you're kind of in a mission now so
that we got we got past all the extreme
climbing or the extreme extreme
traversal this game super Far Cry in
that regards it involves like a lot of
climbing jumping stealth kills but the
interesting thing about the climbing was
before we started the stream and as you
were navigating you were telling me that
you can only climb certain things and
like I guess you have kind of like a
detective vision or kind of like a climb
ovation essentially to tell you hey you
can climb this or hey you can't climb
this this game has a lot of ski
investigating where you hit a scanning
button and you investigate things sort
of one of those things a lot of games
have but it also it also includes
climbing so not everything flammable
they've programmed certain ledges for
climbing I'm skinning you buddy look
your scans that is seems like it's
telling me I can shoot the helicopter
alright you're tagged you're tagged
you're tagged you want to tell the fine
folks at home about sure so later like
we're streaming a cyber ghost warrior 3
currently but at 2 p.m. later Rob and
Mike will be playing titanfall two's new
DLC a glitch in the frontier but for the
time being Aaron's gonna keep scanning
with this drone we're watching twitch
chat YouTube chat game spa chat so if
you guys have questions we'll try to
answer them to the best of our ability
Aaron's played the game way more
extensively than I have so I'll be
deferring on my questions and your
questions to him but yeah we gave it a 5
out of 10
I believe give a hot fiver spot yep it
was let me get our author's name here it
was done by Whichard way clean don't
look at me don't look at me suppression
don't look at me why did he have to look
me I wouldn't had to kill him he didn't
look at me he didn't look why did you
make me kill you yes pick you up okay I
got a buddy here we go I got you as you
normally would you need to get really
evidence as to not whisky anyone to
alarm what he likes snowboarding all
right apparently it's telling making
disable the helicopter I wonder if I can
do sold you the Far Cry style jump kill
in this game just to throw it out to the
audience up there did you guys play the
sniper ghost series how do you like it
compared to say Sniper Elite yeah leave
it just out in the open he tells me
after I've already played this game for
like eight to ten hours so he does he
say that all the time when you have
someone okay at least there's that
that's assuming he actually talks about
half the time he has one-way
conversations with himself I'd like to
think that he has a host of imaginary
friends and I think that's a glitch
maybe it'll get fixed later on yes I did
say 5 out of 10 for those asking and
someone asking why even stream if it's a
5 out of 10 so you guys can also take a
look at it then you guys have an actual
visual look as well as to you know if
you want to buy this game or not you
know and I think they're not as one
person's opinion right
Kirksey there's not a lot of sniping
games out there or games that are sort
of sniping themed there's this Sniper
Elite you can sort of I don't know
there's people have ARMA arm is not very
friendly you can sort of get away with
it and what dragon rising and so it you
know I think people want sniping games
and there's not a ton of them out there
so have you also played the new sniper
early I played through some of it it's
definitely a lot more about exposition
mmm-hmm it's all about the nut shots
hidden hidden dudes in the daddy bags
you actually get like a really good I
don't know like med school level anatomy
lesson when you play that game you're
like yeah oh that's for my spleen is or
like that's what would happen if my
cranium ejected out
my earhole Anthony called the roll if I
said your last name right sorry if I
didn't or actually is called you know
what let me put my glasses on he asks
how are loading times and glitches
loading it's sorry
before you answer call the Rollo call
the roll oh sorry
anyways the loading time was pretty bad
from what I saw just now in terms of
like loading into the game right yeah it
takes a full on ps4 takes a full four
minutes and fifty time - yesterday post
patch it was a full four minutes in 50
seconds to get into the game so and it
also is like about 3 to 4 minutes
between zones but you don't go between
zones that often so I actually don't
think it's that big of a barrier I you
know as with many games like turn a game
on I go do something else for a few
minutes and then come back I don't know
if this is a good idea but I'm gonna do
it anyway I go loud go hot I mean it
said I could shoot these engines I'm not
really sure what it was trying to tell
me that their red bits it's trying to
tell me to blow up the helicopter I mean
they're clearly red don't raise alarm
though man yeah but there's red bits I
don't know I better leave this
helicopter alone just in case hopefully
I don't regret that later on you didn't
check the load time for PC right just I
did not had a chance to check the load
time for PC yet yeah so about a little
under five minutes though for ps4 the
first loading yeah and also like I said
when you go between zones but that's
only every couple hours so I wasn't too
worried about it and in general the
sniping is it's got bullet cam which is
always entertaining or I can actually
drop kill this dude it's entertaining
I like bullet Kim it's not the as I said
the like medical textbook awesome
journal analysis that you get in Sniper
Elite yeah um but it is a good payoff
when you when you get a good stealth
kill and also this game does something
which severs a lot of shooters haven't
done lately which is when you pick up
guns can you not I want to get up there
now when you when you pick up guns off
bad guys you get to keep them they go
into your inventory and there
little bit lower quality and less
customizable than the stuff you buy but
I know I think there's been a bunch of
games I play lately where you pick up
weapons and you don't get to take them
with you it's kind of frustrating all
right I'm trying to drop kill this guy
but I'm sort of having trouble with the
extreme navigation here we go
okay let's see it drop kill totally Far
Cry ok just punched him and that's it I
expect it like some stabber e or
something it does sometimes I punch the
back of his head to death really the
biggest push that I've had our loading
problems where I've had a couple levels
actually was a couple of outposts well
I've had a couple outpost where the bad
guys didn't load in and then the game
crash one no no no no no wait here don't
come here yet we're gonna do the fun way
to kills nope okay bouncing betty no god
damnit menu that is that it nope
select nailed it there we go bouncing
betty here we'll just lower these guys
and let's go buddy over here kill you
and then maybe your friend will see me
good mare come on no breath control he's
45 X come this way no no what Oh failed
I don't want to kill criminal leaders
that's false advertising maybe you need
him for info hot information it was
probably up on the left there what's up
Bob Jim big letters don't kill enemy
leaders also multi players not included
it launched they said they're good it's
delay they're gonna patch it in later
but I did really like multiplayer from
elite to sorry
goes to warrior two easy mistake to make
yeah because it's it is it's fun like
it's all about
all right I just do this more quickly
this time ooh here we go kill shot here
we go look at that sweet rotation ah
gold chain dance I still like the whole
sniper alert elite like there's his
eyeballs there's his head now it's just
cry the whole like x-ray Mortal Kombat
it is satisfying like unquestionably
yeah I was like being unnecessarily
cautious before you do a little Crouch
yeah right in the kisser pucker up
buttercup
all right here we go so the multi-player
in ghost Warrior 2 was really fun
because it was all about positioning
they had a single bridge in the middle
of the map and you could cross it and
kill the other team with pistols
although the pistols were all very slow
firing but if one person covered the
bridge there was no way they were ever
gonna get across it so it was like a
really cool risk/reward map design why
okay um I liked it a lot
and it was cool the maneuver around for
several minutes only to get one kill at
any moment knowing that if somebody sees
you move you were dead it was just
really different from you know the the
kill death loop of battlefield or Call
of Duty or planetside 2 all the other
games I was playing at the time alright
don't raise the alarm eavesdrop on the
conversation wanted how do i eavesdrop
let's eavesdrop with a drone and not get
spotted this time to my journey's drop
or do I have to use my ear holes
oh yeah yeah yeah conversation I'm glad
I listened to that you got the weapons
he said do you got the weapons now I
have two targets now I can okay now we
can kill them in satisfying manners
we're gonna definitely go with bouncing
Betties because that's what snipers do I
might even be able to use a lower bullet
for the first time which would be really
awesome okay can't you just toss the
body that way yeah I don't know you
should leave okay where's my lure bullet
here we go
luring oh no what was that noise
do I have to lure them more really come
on how can I kill you in satisfying
manners if you won't even walk to a
lower Bullet Dubner OSIS we will snipe
all the things well actually that's not
true we're gonna bouncing betty these
two guys while trying to snipe before
them come on elaborate
okay here we go yes you're alerted now
right now they don't care man what all
right you gonna make me kill you the
old-fashioned way can you kill what the
lure boy I don't know let's see yep okay
and the other guy didn't even notice he
was lured come on dude uh you can't see
you can't raise alarm man I killed him
yeah but there's another guy right
behind him all right we're gonna use
there's like a target like up on top
it's what you get for trying to not
snipe in a sniper game all right
apparently I can't kill this guy well
though that guy was not alarmed or maybe
actually the lure bullets probably an
auto fail if you can't use alarms well
you're ready shot like mult
time so like if yeah if they get alarmed
they actually have a little indicator
alright now I'm gonna show you how I
like actually play this game which is
not stealthy at all because you don't
have to its except for that other part
completely unnecessary most the time
so do you trigger that or the game just
triggers that game triggers it every
once in a while go to sleep take a nap
you take a nap - alright
Bartek asking why is everyone playing on
console and not PC that's just
preference actually it's probably
because the dev sent out pays for copy
first and when you play game for several
hours usually you don't want to go back
and restart restarted yeah particularly
if you gave it a hot fiver Anthony
called the rola assuming that's doing
your last name right sorry if I'm not do
you think this game is worth gaming
today or should I wait um so that
depends on what you're looking for if
you're looking for a hot sniping game
this is really the only new one like if
you've already gone through your sniper
elites the sniping in this game is
satisfying and there's a lot of weapons
you can buy there's a lot of ammo types
like one of the interesting parts of
this game is you have to buy all your
bullets all of your bullets like the
ones you don't scavenge for you don't
actually scavenge once your sniper rifle
that I found yet so yeah
I find that to be interesting mmm so
yeah there's there is fun to be had here
and I'm interested to see what happens
if they're multi no no no no no god
dammit why did my drone get spotted that
time it wasn't high enough I guess well
apparently I can raise alarms yes I
guess you just can't kill him yeah do
some extreme navigation Johnny hi we do
see your messages by the way it was a
thing I could go up that way or down
that way
go around do some hot FarCry climbing um
okay so yeah dancer that know what you
sick you pointed out the thing I trusted
you look good
oh just no I trust I trusted him he was
like he was pointing at it he's like I'm
gonna go there did the the climb ovation
tell you you could go there I don't know
it's the point of vision he's got
climate vision and point of vision where
he like points of things a man just cuz
he points at it maybe he's like a maybe
I can get there maybe
well now I'm thinking I can raise alarms
because despite this a fact I just said
don't raise the alarm should we try the
totally loud blade there since we've
done this three times now I guess so as
long as you can finish the mission
ownage ownage is I think it's only just
rule I do like the drone gameplay you
really have an idea that you're flying a
drone and not moving a fixed camera oh
there's a stab oh there you go
yeah the drone itself is a bit sketchy
to control I didn't like it at first but
to be honest it grew on me mmm it does
feel like you're flying a you know a
physical drone that's a bit difficult
what's up Andrew Brewers I see you or we
see you San Sam Kazemi has been playing
on PC for last 10 hours hope you're
doing I do wish that the sniping was a
bit more tricky
whose I your your Chuck that boy have
you got bullet curved so how this is now
wanted now straight wanted right there
cuz if I flick my wrist no no no no no
no no why what so maybe I can come in on
this anger didn't notice me before okay
here we go now I'm listening are you
though does he have the guns do you have
the guns it looks like he has guns so if
I can like hover in this way later Phil
Hudson have a good day thanks for
stopping by come back for a titanfall
coach in the frontier later
Bartek I don't know why you can't
download it through Steam sorry
hopefully someone in the chat can help
you out there talking I'm eavesdropping
oh do I have to physically be 32 meters
forward no okay I think it's saying that
I have to physically be closer to them
for some reason he's dropped with my ear
holes it's just these drop of their ear
holes oh he's gotta make a call oh there
you go now you got to interrogate the
criminals leader okay we can do that
which one's the leader I'm assuming ball
I think was a suit right yeah yeah cuz
the other guy was a lieutenant I think
oh oh you're body's there remember that
guy you killed Oh fine okay so I can
kill this guy which way is he facing not
at you
oh and the other guy didn't even hear it
alright you've been in to your surprise
square to interrogate boss q85 asking
what game can you compare this game to
gameplay wise it's very far cry I would
say very maybe Far Cry 2 even a lot of
the climbing shooting wolves attacking
you in the middle of nowhere it feels
very far inspired alright [ __ ] F yeah
drop his body no reason to drop f-bombs
yeah he's got trading goods all the
beans cuz he's just getting choked we're
gonna make a bean salad with all those
beans he spills umm I can tell you some
of the good hunter Sawyer let me look at
the our review the good missions are
often spacious and promote choice and
variety cycling mechanics are satisfying
which Aaron has also said and it
simulates the methodical precision of
being an elite marksman there's also
some bad there but we can read that
later and so going back sorry I kind of
zoned out on my question about whether
you should be playing this game or not
it depends what you're into actually a
lot of people right now are playing
player knowns battlegrounds which I have
had a lot of fun with its Battle Royale
parachute onto a map scavenge guns and
then kill other players and if you're
lucky you get to pick up a sniper rifle
from a weapons drop you've also got you
got titanfall glitch in the front here
coming out today which a nice fast
travel no no it's gonna make me walk off
this map Sara trail here I can just take
so I don't have to do that
no PvP yeah right I'm reading that it's
a free update coming PvP is going to be
a free update yes
and I did very much enjoy the PvP from
the last game let's see if I can Xtreme
navigate down this way so it actually
makes you go all the way back you have
to exfiltrate which just means get out
of the zone each time all right what are
the chances I can survive this fall not
very likely all right
talking me into doing smart thing I'm
just trying to not get black loading
screens climb down um
battlegrounds titanfall I feel like I
don't know for some reason I feel like
battlefield the one's kind of already
played out it was a good idea but I just
wasn't enough there to keep everybody
entertained but you know that's up to
you maybe some of you were still playing
battlefield 1 Call of Duty's got a map
pack yep
that was last week right last week cuz
the new zombies was out less all right
I'm better I could ski this we're gonna
try we're gonna do this I really hope
you don't have to redo oh we're gonna
make it we're skiing alright
that worked better than I thought
schemas sliding
Corvo attano asking how big is the open
world each zone is like about that big
about yay big and I think I've seen it
looks to be about four to six zones so
I've only done two zones so far that's
pretty big though I spent about eight
hours I think in the first zone so yeah
it's it is a sizable sniping environment
six-year success so sniper ghost Warrior
is not just the title they're actually
play styles that you unlock so once we
get back to our base of us has been to
Rowand seems like that bastard fossil
has got impatient to take the reins
spilled all the beans all of them all of
the beans are spilled juice recon wait
there I mentioned this group 23 society
but I'm not supposed to be talking to my
friend right now it's Ocelot
I'm assuming there's somebody who's
supposed to be on the other end of that
radio but I have not heard their voice
yet okay nope still talking sorry dude
that's who I met with them says he met a
mozzie looked like he was going to piss
his pants just saying the name Kong lol
saying my favorite game is time fall to
you well fun fact
at 2:00 p.m. Rob and Mike will be
playing a glitch in the frontier the new
DLC for titanfall 2 so definitely come
back at 2:00 p.m. for that andre brewer
asking if you know how long the
single-player campaign mode is I could
only guess right now but it seems fairly
lengthy again like here the zones I
spent about 8 hours in the first zone
you're looking probably at 40 or 50
hours at least but that was you doing
some side stuff too right in the first
zone and whatnot
yeah it depends on how much you want to
get into the scanning for atrocities and
interesting taking down bases like you
would in Far Cry there's a lot of other
stuff you can do or you can just sort of
mainline the story story yeah Thank You
lopaka game for the kind words says
loving the he or she says loving the
stream thank you also hello Galatea I
don't we want to talk about a broader
topic well actually shut the basement
alright sure that base off so every
every zone has a base in this cave yeah
it's gay base you can actually now I
think when they originally show this off
at e3 you had to go up to every station
but now you can just go up to one
station and use your shoulder buttons
that's good buy other stuff so those are
all your guns yeah so here's the
modification system this so the Aki
picked up and the OFM 500 I picked up
and you'll see that you can keep them if
you pick them up which I love but you
can't really customize them much which I
also think it's kind of cool wildlands
that was the game that pissed me off you
couldn't pick up guns and wildlands and
keep them that was annoying I thought
that game sort of missed the ball in
that one so here are the guns that I can
purchase and or are you so far
in this game a bullet seems to be a
bullet so I don't really know why other
than aesthetic reasons you would want
both action versus semi-auto
because a headshot is a headshot so far
and so why would you not want immediate
follow-up rounds that's why I've been
rolling with this make sense but you
have all impact I guess you're right
head shots a headshot so yeah why would
you ever and also the bullet you can you
know you can have different bullet types
but what if you want to be the sniper in
Saving Private Ryan I mean I think
people who like sniping games also just
enjoy rolling with certain sniper rifles
just because they are fun and they feel
good um I could I've got plenty of cash
I could buy a new rifle let's just buy
one there we go
bought this you do have to pay attention
to the caliber because you might not
have the bullets and you do have to buy
all of your bullets no nice man let's
pick up some more expensive some scope 6
8 10 or whoa this one goes up 24 I
haven't tried that yet let's get a 20
you really need to zoom from that far
the gameplay I just saw from you I want
to see into a man's soul when I put a
bullet into his Johnny hi we are
currently not playing on a ps4 Pro but
he also asks can this reach 60 FPS have
not tested that yet so I can't really
give you an answer
little bipod stability does they give
you stability I'm guessing yep but
there's also there's also sniping spots
so it depends on the mission so there we
go I just bought a sick sniper rifle
what is our caliber on this array of 25
rounds
this has tagging luring regular I have
run out of bullets you have to be
careful so let's make sure we buy a full
stack hey man what kind of sniper are
you guys got a clip you got a hope for
the best I have not run into the enemy
the gates level yet okay what maybe I'm
full not full of bullets right now great
movie by the way if you guys are in this
night
enemy enemy yeah yeah enemy the gates
that is a good one
here's like all the different types of
rounds you can buy different calibers I
think the arrows were actually DLC okay
I can buy 760 you are more penetrating
or sorry armor-piercing but I don't
think the rifle that I just unlocked can
support it got you
hendrik you can use a bipod on your life
you need more stability in life sure do
it I don't know how that would work for
you but you can try it so to be fair
there's not a lot of windage and bullet
drop in this game okay so I had somebody
dead on then it's like COD have actually
found them good combination the best way
to play this game is just kana do the
equivalent of running gun sniping
oh sorry also the sorry but the skills
menu so sniper ghost and warrior your
allotted points depending on your actual
what you do prosecution of each mission
so I got some I got four points in
warrior right now we can do get an
additional gadget slot or we can reload
faster
it's a sniping you know if you have to
reload faster it's gonna that's like if
you're playing that kind of so I was
gonna ask you right like so you
obviously have these three skill trees
right yeah have you felt like this has
changed how you approach or play the
game cuz like you know obviously skill
trees kind of looking at them like
warrior right like that's something like
where you go may be more guns hot you
know like you're you're going in with
like an assault rifle or something like
that these skills tend to momís trust
this guy just make you better what
you're already doing not by a huge
margin because again it's a sniping game
right most of what you're doing is just
scanning a base figuring out a route and
then this just keeps getting better and
popping dudes in their noggins you can't
go in guns blazing I'm on one above
normal difficulty they tend to be very
aggressive so it's hard to survive once
you get spotted you have to run
yeah uh Brandon parks is a question is
there a hardcore mode with no HUD one
hint death there is um I don't know if
it's one hit death why are settings
gotcha let's go thanks hunter Sawyer for
gifts of me and hope you tune in to
challenge Oh interesting so challenge
can turn off HUD menus show weapon no
gadget no health and armor let's just
turn it all off and see what now oh yeah
we go on go on fold no HUD huh
I like it alright let's go no HUD and I
have not tried it this hard yet we'll
see what happens is there a game when
Julian YouTube chat asking is there a
day/night cycle dynamic whether there's
a day/night cycle I've not run in
dynamic weather you can get in your bed
and sleep until it's a night mission and
then put on your night-vision goggles
which is it's weird though cuz nighttime
tents at least in this this region
nighttime has a full moon all the time
so it's still very bright so I can't
fully tell if they're not spotting me at
night because I'm wearing envy jeez I'd
have to test that it almost feels weird
putting on night-vision goggles when you
have a full moon because you can still
see everything perfectly yeah let me
make sure I'm going the right way
because we turned our head off what
happens if you do go for the lower
region do they die in one shot
nope I'm going the wrong way so we
turned our head off already the
challenge begins challenge one is
navigate to the location when you've
turned your head off wonder if I can
I'll just have Aaron try later when if I
can win this do it Canyon Bob alright
someone saying you can jump off a
building with that buggy and survive I
feel like that can't be true that is
from prophet of regret DT in YouTube yet
I'm sure you can gonna dr. strange
yourself man
we're gonna survive Falls from high
places like a cat
hendrik I'm not gonna try your last name
in YouTube asking how would you rate the
death animations oh ragdoll physics so
far uh like on a scale of like - yeah
how do you I mean guys heads kind of go
into their bodies sometimes when they
ragdoll so we need to make a left turn
this is what happens when you go
somebody convinces me to go hard course
to go hood yeah
suddenly I have to actually figure out
how to get places yeah that's like
reading a map that's how you would have
to in real life that was one of my
biggest issues with far cry 2 was
everything was an in-game map so it was
this gorgeous
game set in Africa and you spent the
entire time like looking at a map okay
in your face that was the entire game so
I only like minimaps for directions I
don't like minimaps for enemy location
because first of all that's cheating and
second of all you spend too much time
looking at it but it can be challenging
when you're trying to navigate any game
just here yeah I think he just wanted us
to go up the road let's see this is
better than what happened in Mass Effect
Andromeda where it told me to make a
phone call that I had to fly and do
orbit and waste millions of dollars and
like electricity to make a phone call to
a planet and then land back on the
planet and talk to the guy so there
Marko fire it's kind of open world right
like region-based open world region
based up in the world each region is
sizable I don't think you have you know
a lot of it is it's like again it's like
Far Cry where it's your biggest reason
to stop is to either investigate these
question marks which that are usually
murder / atrocities sometimes you pick
up drones or to clear out outposts in a
very far cry fashion alright prophet and
YouTube chat I'll get Erin to try later
maybe after this mission he says that
the whole jumping off a mountain with a
buggy will work but we don't have to try
that right now well we'll do this
mission that we'll try it I believe you
I don't know man I I've been burnt in
chat before I believed chat during our
over water now stream okay yep totally
works that was not that high though but
I probably do not want to just drive up
to this base because it says don't
provoke the criminals this drone out
also since I got rid of my hut I
actually don't know my drone can hack
now apparently oh yeah did they just not
man they're roadside kind of criminals
are these it's got a mad max-style
checkpoint here and they're not even
manning it
yes Bob I always bring up the overwatch
chat that was you guys rekt me chat rekt
me so hard oh look this is a nice look
yeah just that's pretty dope actually my
crates house crate housing I can relate
you know living in the Bay Area I've
researched crate housing and decided
it's a dumb idea but still hey it could
work out man people are living in like
boxes and people's living rooms at this
point so philanthropy the sniping is
about to get started again we we're on
another mission we're gonna I'm gonna
have Aaron try to nut shot somebody and
see what that does see if we can get you
all a kill Kim to the nuts
Johnny hi and YouTube chat asking are
there boss fights in this game not that
I've run into yet there's a there's like
a guy with a ghost helmet who ambushes
you at one point and then shoots the
helmet out of your hand or maybe the
element as a flash bulb inside and
that's as far as I've gotten with boss
fights
I got flashed in the eyeballs and then
it ended because I was hoping I was
about to have a you know big old sniper
fight yeah all right back to our mission
of sniping somebody in the nards see if
we can't get you all in our shot alright
this guy that guy he's never know it's
not gonna know what
Adam I have to crouch on this mhmmm only
right through the butt problem hole the
problem with the butt shot is it's a two
shot by shot Oh what is cheap
let's try so what's gonna happen off to
reload but no there's your rag doll what
all right retransmission at least you'd
know that it kills him in a one shot
though
confirmed one shot to the cornhole will
kill a man a 50 Cal she killed those
boogie man in like two shots the guys
with the mask sorry thanks prophet Joe
DiMaggio if you want to get this for PvP
weights they have not put it in the game
yet a free update though free update
we're currently playing on at ps4 which
people asked earlier we started on ps4
because that's what the developer sent
us first Anton we can't just rush in and
kill them apparently because we're not
supposed to provoke them according to
the this might be might be a ghost
mission where you actually know stealth
it who got the alert though I'm confused
because he's the guy up top but to your
right like probably somewhere up there
maybe or the guy up there talking that
lady I see what you're doing mission
everybody's talking to somebody so I
can't just do my favorite thing which is
not listen to the mission - tag to make
the division - I used to be able to
defend the division and then I can't
defend it anymore wildlands is very
popular right now I gotta say so you
think that from their learnings after
the division going into wild lands that
like there will be some spawn of those -
for like a division - that's what I'm
hoping
division was too much of an RPG for my
taste I just want a bullet to be a
bullet wildlands didn't really have
enough of a like a tactical identity in
my opinion although it was totally
adequate can I not what he's our friend
he don't wanna fight man oh you're not
gonna alert okay well then doesn't care
that you have a gun man well then oh
good
dick set the alarm off before you're
just not supposed to provoke the
criminals maybe they think you're
friendly is it because I've got an ak-47
I got naked guys we're buddies right
maybe you can go bet on that fight it
over there what if I what if I provoke
the [ __ ] you provoke the chickens and
see I think I can just walk in and see
what happens
yeah yeah this is gonna work as well
just real casual guys here we're good
everybody's cool everybody stay cool
nothing going on here there are that guy
one bloodbath well [ __ ] I bet on the
other guy so and you better pay up then
all right
you think the bookmaker he makes books
looking for the man at the top look at
me look at me when you're talking to me
[Music]
don't do it yet yeah are we betting on
the crusher Vlad the crusher or on Avari
man how do you bet against Vlad the
crusher though man I think the other guy
doesn't even have like a cool like
wrestling name you got Vlad the crusher
and then he just got on Avari I mean
they're trying to make you overthink it
maybe yeah once for Vlad to spur on
Avari I'll let chat catch up who would
you have picked if I didn't tell you to
wait for chat I feel like when they
haven't evil add the crusher they're
baiting you to pick the wrong guy
but then you could be overthinking it
unless meta I got a Google on vari and
see if that means something even more
badass and like Charlie Georgian or it
could just be a name it's probably just
a name I mean on the other hand on vari
has a gold chain necklace excuse me so
that means that he's you know probably
want a couple fights I don't I don't
think there's anything crashing yeah
like what if it is the meta that like
you think the crusher is gonna crush it
but really
but the the no nickname guy is gonna
probably just win a lot of people saying
crusher there's only been two people
that have would bet on on Avari I guess
you can go
you're gonna go crusher anyways we're
getting even mixed I was gonna go with
on vibe oh are you okay
yeah just like he's got a gold chain but
he's got a hood man bet on the guy with
the hood more better
he's got the hood but he's not giving it
full Phelps face so I'm not thinking
he's in the zone yet Oh see look at that
I want some crush' all right we're going
crazy the crash has been on crasher all
right here we go I wonder if the mission
hinges on you guys
I will laughs if you can fail this oh
look at that little respect little
respect
all right crusher you got this you gotta
live up to your name I feel like you
have the name crusher you have to live
up to that name
yeah crushers hoody a little jab right
jab ooh who's got combinations Oh
crusher come on you're not no he's good
that was just a push off okay can't zoom
or something oh no buddy glad he's hurt
Vlad's hurt oh he's going for the he's
going for that no no I feel like I
should be able to make it rain while
they're fighting right feel the toss
dollars that or at least fist pump like
that other guy who'll Oh headbutt oh
that's not legal in most leagues now
this is this is the street fights man
this is the street can you tap out in
this next two because simple TV man
saltybet was so good back in the day
leather jacket leather jacket oh no a
butt kick you got it in the butt shot
okay tailbone shot got him in the
tailbone I hate it when that happens
Anton Jensen welcome to the UFC it's
time thank you Bruce Buffer
he's turtling up oh this is not good
this is not good man our guy looks Oh
sweep the leg oh and he's
my leg yeah the crusher torn like a dog
tuck you just had to sweep the leg I got
to say that is an awful lot of blood on
the ground there's a lot of fight man
this is what they do they're friendly
it's all good you got to get respect
that's a good fight man
good fight it's just like you see man
all right didn't you piss off the
criminals let's bet on how many punches
I give you before you have permanent
brain damage
permanent brain what you're a big guy I
think in between 30 and 40 sounds tiring
this guy is interrogating let's mean
next level man he gets the other guy to
spill the beans right you know Ted
locking him when they do this how can
you not pull the trigger and then don't
do it
no no all right please Oh John Cena you
can't see me baby and then he just
threatens this guy hey Aaron I'm gonna
punch you 30 to 40 times in the head if
you don't tell me who I need to talk to
I'm gonna point out the faulty logic in
that I feel like if a sniper punches a
man 30 to 40 times his shooting hand is
not gonna be so steady after that he
didn't think that one through permanent
brain damage
yeah brofist oh we can take them down
there that's weird I feel like I should
be on the brofist why can't I prefer oh
we in the club oh okay all right
have we been done we're gonna bet on
stripper fights now Oh - all right yet
one or two I'm looking for
I'll set up a meeting the friend who
might know something in the meantime why
don't you take a break
oh thank you this is all IKEA furniture
right find some company and enjoy
yourself for a few hours
black lights so you use black lights and
surf clubs if you like okay she's like
trying to get me to like you know
anything about Avice no okay we know
something about Avice you know hey hey
bro do you know anything about
Avice go look at the guy on the bench
tell me they don't look the same
I'm gonna punch you 30 to 40 times if
you don't talk I feel like that guy
anymore the same guys the other guy came
for the sniping stay for the pit
fighting the matrix
it's the sleazeball underscore one MPC
we're in the matrix now oh what up dude
he's not having as a champagne VIP room
though I'm thinking like water bottles
hey don't do drugs generally okay how
many drugs
what's going on up here like how she's
trying to get him to hook up with one of
the the strippers and then he
immediately changes his tone of voice
and she freaks out these are the beds
for moves like that it's like taken they
just got the the bead physics you know I
have a particular set of skills and they
don't get to the barrier class oh yeah
oh he's not making it rain though oh
yeah make it rain we're doing we're
doing a service
hey you're not appreciating okay that
was too much 20 bucks there should be 20
bucks goddamn we can't make any money in
this joint Agent Smith this is Steven
Boscovich
what kind of game is this apparently
it's not a sniper it's where we bet on
pit fights and go to the strip club so
it's really GTA yeah we dance at the
strip club yeah we're next level in the
strip club and now we're showing the
strippers some moves all right we get
into the barracks we're gonna go down
some elevator why can't I brofist I
really just want a brofist oh yeah I'm
not supposed to piss them off but I
can't brofist I'm confused
all right here we go totally not secret
elevator
there's no co-op initiate now that was
from mr. preach there is no cult place
in wild lands if you want come on that
game is pretty much heard it's not that
fun when you're by yourself though wild
lands it's way way way more fun with
friends it's just bill for friends this
way I'm a gamer if you give me a side
route I'm always gonna yeah you just
have to go look because there might be
some crate that then has like an
adrenaline packing just like why did I
come grab that adrenalin impact oh let
the old man go I agree with the American
I already think you should listen shut
up okay I'll give you a lap dance
Western North how lucky for us to meet
again drop the weapon I've got a weapon
it was one try it seems you have me in a
bit of a spot so how about we play a
little game
Oh another game your games Jonathan you
don't get it I'm in control
no there are three [ __ ] and three
realms in this pistol if the old man
dies you got to ask me all about Robert
if you die the old man walks and you
I'll be dead of course you could shoot
me now and save the old man but deep
down you want to know about your brother
but if I go Kaiser says they ain't just
killed man and the chair exactly
shall we begin I'll show you exactly one
congratulations all the men you live to
annoy another day I can see the bullets
in there but you don't really think that
130
yeah but we're screwed now we can't find
out about our brother grandfather yes
this old bastard is all I have I mean yo
dead now I think the worst bad guy ever
I don't want to be in the game me please
working with well as I am no longer in
immediate danger what a lap you have
been that bad happy to help but let's
get out of here first
I haven't been outside for days caveats
I gotta get that vitamin D
seriously like what you're doing down he
knew what he was doing he clearly didn't
want you to get information so he had
three bullets and he could have just
fired three bullets into me and then
that would have solved the problem then
you wouldn't be playing a game Aaron he
wanted to play a game I'm surprised you
didn't use your expert interrogating and
like scare tactics like you have been
with everyone else who seems like this
cower when you you know he'd tell them
hey
that guy must have failed bad guy school
no dude that's the best kind of bad guy
he like made you think real deep yeah he
probably failed that guys why would he
even have like he knew you're covering
so he's like I'm gonna I want to play a
game I'm gonna put three bullets here
then we're gonna play rushing can we go
talk to bone crusher
yo my man wait a way to win me that bet
he's sure bet all right
oh they got more than one pit I didn't
even notice that they got multiple
fights at one time they might even have
a like one of those rooster fights right
there send the roosters out oh yeah we
did it yeah was I a sniper or a ghost or
a warrior you were none of the above
how did you have a hundred oh I guess
cuz you never missed you never shot
either I just unlocked the three three
eight darpa I'm kind of all right go
figure out what that is in case you guys
were just joining us we are playing
sniper it goes to warrior three
according to this system but Aaron is
doing some missions we just finished
another one where we got to bet on a pit
fight then we talked to a madam that has
like a strip club at like this great
area video you lead let her kill jump in
with an assist from time we gave a lap
dance and then we met the worst bad guy
ever yeah let's play a game I killed
myself ah I really didn't think that one
through
haha no seriously I failed back yes like
how you're like I see the bullet you're
gonna kill yourself now I'm back to
talking to my imaginary friend there is
no wind bullet drop at epidemic the
sniping aaron has said and even our
reviewer Richard wake Lena says pretty
satisfying but there isn't any like
bullet drop right
anything like that you put the radical
on the guy and they go splat fire book
is saying the best part was the betting
yeah it was a pretty even match then we
swept his weak leg we got a mine
armour-piercing alright cuz you're
fighting tanks yep
I've not bought a tank yet actually we
should probably stock up on drugs
because these are kind of important when
you're playing hardcore okay well I
guess we have drugs and I don't see that
DARP around
umm I think that's mother-effing John
short Jordan we will you taught asking
is this installment more open world or
still semi linear more uh-huh more as a
relative term uh-oh loading we're
loading is this the five minute loading
no I don't know why though I loaded a
mission who's alerting the next zone
yeah we got to the next own four minutes
and 50 seconds potentially there's no I
think it's only the first load but
that's that is I don't know though we'll
see enjoy that hot music I'm assuming
from Georgia sup moomin what's the dance
to this I don't know we need to get the
strip club back
yeah we just did a loading screen oh no
this is a five-minute loading is it so
Aaron time this on ps4 it was five
minutes and forty no more more minutes
50 seconds this is a loading screen
music Noah
we need the loading screen dance are you
guys playing one of the games everybody
playing right now is every playing wall
Lance cuz it keeps topping the charts
and that the game was fun but kinda
mediocre and then people keep buying it
so I think you guys are all playing
wildlands right now ah there are a lot
of good games out at least in this like
first four months of the year you know
you have like Zelda yeah persona have
all these games but I guess in terms of
a shooter I guess you got a good point
maybe wildlands is disables it still
owning where yeah we got a while guys
trust me that's gonna be another two to
three minutes of loading go get a cup of
coffee take a pee break
exactly you could probably get a poop
break and maybe that one time yeah you
could probably make coffee drink it get
your poop break in then come back in
your radius night Joe DiMaggio the four
minutes 50 seconds was loading at least
the first time from like the initial
like game menu to the to the knee I
guess your first your mission area and
then now we've probably just finished
another zone or region and I think we're
probably like you know loading into the
next region right suppose yeah nothing
without the same that one might not have
been as long I don't know rented jix
says co-op and while bands is fun yeah
and that game is just totally Belford
it's funny I'm always it's always a
toss-up between games that are built for
sniping and games that just happen to
have good sniping in them I actually
measure most sniping games against far
cry 4 which had some of the most
intensely satisfying sniping I've ever
done unless you want the internal kill
cam in which case sniper elite is way
more arcadey but you get the nice
anatomy lesson
yeah those hot x-ray shots
what's your loading screen dance who
knows
I got a BF one
yeah Dirk II can't argue with that
battlefield has intensely satisfying
shooting Conrad asking is the game good
we gave it a hot five hot five out of
ten which means it is falls in the like
adequate range if you like sniping games
these sniping in this game is fun I
enjoy sniping it's considered mediocre
by our standards I'm looking at the
review right now but yeah we're almost
there this loading screen is almost
there this is one of the gripes right
the loading screen and supposedly some
glitches but we Aaron hasn't seen too
many of the coaches yeah our reviewer
said he saw some T poses but I have I'm
kind of jaded right now after playing
Mass Effect Andromeda I don't even know
what a broken game means anymore like
Mass Effect Andromeda was just
thoroughly busted from start to a
hundred hours that way I'm currently at
so I think they lowered the bar so much
that now I think this games loading
screens aren't bad
Chamorro saying wait it's still loading
I went to get a coffee nice that's what
you should do
Wade nice to see you again Wade in the
YouTube chat saying hey Erin and Eric do
you guys feel the overly loud long load
times are worth the in-game times
I've spent quite a few hours in each
region so as long as you're not
transitioning between regions that's
fine and I like honestly you can play a
region and then you need a break anyway
so you just load the next region go like
to the bathroom get a coffee come back
and you're ready to go yeah it's you
know yeah I don't you guys remember back
in the day when connect was the thing
Connect used to tell you to take a break
hey you've been playing for a long time
maybe it's time for a break and um was
it Final Fantasy 15 that did that I feel
like there was a game more recently in
the last six months that Oh gave you a
warning
damn it loaded me what he's not going to
[ __ ] it loaded me back to the first
region sick part of the main line story
what the okay that was unnecessary so I
went to the second region yeah started
the mission and it loaded us back to the
first region well go back to the other
region I only did 58% of the main
missions there apparently that was
confusing did I was that me did I do
that let me double-check really quick
really hope you didn't I wasn't paying
attention I was reading chat so I was
just going down through the journals
nope it definitely sent us back to the
first region dude
Anton if for some reason they announced
blood-borne 2 which is like I don't know
how they would I would lose my [ __ ] not
only would you lose your [ __ ] you would
have plenty of time to lose your [ __ ]
yeah tween loading screen somebody in
the chat asked if this is for PC it's
both current consoles and PC the he was
over people still talking about
blood-borne even to this day wasn't
there better exclusives out already I
mean there hasn't technically been
better exclusives for that kind of game
I mean you could argue that neo was a
very solid game but I still think
blood-borne was better than you for that
genre of game but back to the task at
hand here we're gonna test we're gonna
test that cliff oh that's super cliff
theory cliff there on we good
yeah you're in the water though can I
Drive in the water let me drive I'm
surprised you're not where's the fish
there's a fish fish I love fish all
right so that's pretty high up yeah yeah
there was actually I've been meaning to
get down here for a crash car let's go
oh yeah Ian I want to go see and
investigate the crash car oh you can do
that Thanks oh you look good having a
good day just to get get old zombie that
you know zombie drivers are the worst I
just got a guy throw that out there
zombies just make the worst drivers all
right time to swim and let's like in
fast travel I might be able to actually
yeah I can fast travel okay time to fast
travel we jumped off that cliff profit
nice breathing mechanics yeah we don't
we don't struggle uh Anton I wouldn't
say it's neo is trash compared to
blood-borne I think Neil is a very good
game but you just must have a love for
blood-borne I see why though wow that
joke stunk more than that long opening
screen fair enough
what nobody likes just drivers I guess
so yeah good no problem nailed it oh I
can't get out you can't it'll be fine
we're good still good going sideways now
no problems we're out and that car is
strategy to driving a good sniping spot
so we can actually show people some good
long-range sniping yeah I get to a hill
at least a fast travel was fastest so
that's what the the developer was saying
that part of the reason for the long
loading time was because they wanted to
make sure once you're in a zone like
everything's there everything's there no
pop in yeah it was pop in not too bad
okay I mean I really have not I ran into
a1 outpost that crash consistently but
actually I've not run into many bugs
okay no that's not true so far every
single conversation I've had is
I haven't been able to hear the other
person talking to me which okay it's
actually pretty big
that's a pretty big bug not gonna lie so
the loading screen time is also a PC we
haven't tested that Cyprian that was
from you to chat we haven't tested PC
some people saying not as bad on PC
especially with SSD but you know still
alright we're gonna get to make some
range shots here which should be nice
these are suggested sniping spots this I
played this at e3 two years ago this was
the first level that they showed coming
full circle here nice two years later
he's back I remember that two years ago
they're like oh hey you can't run again
this game and I'd pretty much just did
it alright 123 meters is the first time
we've actually had to dial in our range
oh nice so 150 unfortunately I can't go
125 so we'll go let's go 100 which means
we gotta aim what a little bit high I
think
so our windage is 9 I'm assuming meters
a seconds
mm basically negligible not much going
on and we got the cool adjustable scare
up so we can peer into this man's soul
while he's smoking while he's smoking
smoking is gonna kill you bro
does that mean he's dead that means he's
dead right did he get the enemy yeah
yeah from smoking okay I was just
wondering if it would ever play the
animation and have you miss look I just
saved in the trouble he was gonna die of
cancer anyway
through the fence
Oh as his eyeball no so someone came out
the other side watch out there's a guy
there's still is there the panel no he's
saying spread out oh he got away you're
terrible sniper and can I lower him we
should try the ridiculous idea of always
hit the wrong be pad he pads are not my
friend I guess that makes sense launch
the drone up
there's my medicine here we go okay
let's see if this guy is no it's only
tagging
well I'm trying tagging we could attack
him to death all right let's try tagging
him to death oh we lost our range just a
tagging bullet have to hit though I
don't know what happens nope
whoa awesome serious scanning [ __ ]
well then I'm worried that he's actually
running at us because that happens in
this game are you running at us because
that could be a problem
where are they at okay where'd you go
buddy he's right behind the shed he's
like f that dude there's a there's a
sniper those scan Bulls are not working
as advertised well it doesn't look like
it has a huge scan line I mean you just
gotta get it closer to him maybe I don't
know no problem no fall damage strongest
legs don't skip leg day guys then you
can do stuff like that well I was
kidding don't ever try that ever I think
that would result in broken bones let's
make sure that zero our sniper rifle and
I don't know who's gonna use that car in
the turret mmm it says locked when you
try and do it unfortunate what up buddy
I'm just gonna do a little slide deck
off the books it was what right yep whew
he's so good OOP all right time to go eh
K this is not a sniping game anymore
god I just made my first kill is a day
I don't have we're playin hard or we're
playing hard no HUD right I guess that
answers that question I think I took
around and didn't die so I think in the
hardcore mode you still don't well is
that actually the hardcore mode though
like are you on the hardest difficulty -
yeah so you got you got some room for
air later no Davis thanks for stopping
by and hanging out watching the screen
if you have time later we got another
stream at two o'clock later guys
titanfall 2 DLC a glitch in the front
here I think it's a new map
that'll be Rob and Mike and don't forget
we got some streams tomorrow we playing
some cod in the morning some old-school
cod and then that's not 9 a.m. and then
we also will be doing the lobby tomorrow
got a bunch of streams this week we also
have a mario kart like switch version
tournament come Friday
okay that's night Breville also if you
guys enjoy a streaming just throw us
like or subscribed if you're ever on
youtube we make our decisions on how
much and when we stream based on your
guys input and like how much you guys
want us to exactly alright wait for
agents hey the hue is over I said first
of all you didn't preface that you guys
can't skip leg day and then second of
all I also said after the fact that
that's probably not safe don't do it
cover the agents where is the agent he's
over there how you gonna cover him with
your aka alright I got the gig gun
alright let's get a range first he's got
a cover here range mm 230 meters up up
up up what what don't reach that scope
something I told you to do all right so
let's go
Oh 300 meters on the nose what 230 its
go they always give you these ranges
that are right in between the two all
right let's go 200 and we'll just aim a
little high
anton jensen you might I mean like won't
be shocked if you get most of that
coming III but who knows what oh forgot
windage yeah you got okay
I thought you didn't I thought there's
no bullet drop but there is 50 50 meter
gotta deal with the elements nope what
am I like how he's not like fazed by
anything gay there we go did the other
bullets not whiz by his head then think
you lost a little bit of a brain track
there no I know but I'm just saying like
the other bullets he shot did they not
whiz by his head there's a lot more
windage on these shots like how are they
not being alarmed by the fact that
you're missing like that there you go
that guy knows what's up
no God dang it what the ooh
how is he able to shoot you with an ax
is he sniping is he counter sniping you
must have been alright yeah
so that's the first time the game
through some really good windage at me
and we're on the hardest mode so it's
not giving us much help well you know
you gotta get good as the Internet's try
it again
oh man
ex-squeeze-me says I hope God of War
comes out this year who knows I was
really cool to see it last year though
at e3 hoping for some big announcements
at e3 but Hardin what are they destiny -
that's neat - will probably like be
announced because they've already I mean
they had that leaked release date and
they're gonna show gameplay and like
next month I think during that
livestream one May 18th so that's
probably gonna be there for sure I was a
little disappointed with the fact that
they wrecked the tower I think it's kind
of a cop-out because that was a huge fan
of the grimoire and all the lore in that
game and there was so much good stuff
about the the last city I was hoping we
would go there not not the destroyed
version of it you know maybe there's
still some part of it that's good it's
still there okay 250 meters to target
we're a doped in 250 the windage is a
little weird nope
man my rounds are really fast all right
you just put it on the tip of his head
no high what I
still don't get how this guy doesn't get
alarmed but the other guy immediately
gets alarmed oh is right between the
eyes
okay those pretty decent physics that I
think I got this figured out with like
how he died
target number two oh he's is he
binocular in you Oh nailed it no
animation that guy was different too
than the last guy you fought I'm Dow
then all right are you good
target number 300 right over his head Oh
a little bit oh it's right over the
shoulder there we go
oh right in the ear hole I've shot one
kill
yeah you shot what your agent was killed
cuz you didn't protect them just because
I delivered five shots one kill you went
from being a marksman to then being a
rookie all over it alright one more
attempt we are on the hardcore mode
where you don't get much help what one
of the game's gonna crash I'm gonna
crash game and then we can listen to
sick georgian music are you think that
do you think that's how it goes though
oh wait what did you do did you actually
do the redo the mission okay you're good
you're good
we're gonna do with this time it's gonna
happen I need to bring my high velocity
around Anton who knows if there will
actually be a release day for Kingdom
Hearts 3 man but like every year that
people hope for it just hasn't happened
I'll be surprised when it actually
happens you know wonder if I can pull my
suppressor off you can try some people
were saying
arnica way yeah okay he was definitely
not killed by a pistol unless it was the
agent that was killed by pistol and
that's different
250 all right here we go here we go
third time's a charm fire bucket you're
right third time's a charm so what's
going on high note in the windage might
actually be telling me based on Oh bang
it's going up right the wind okay I get
it the windage is actually giving you
the mill dog I was smoking some dead the
game's giving you the windage based on
your male dog don't feel like that's
where you hit him in the head but
alright okay fair 280 meters so let's go
300 aim a little bit low and we need to
be on our second looks like we need to
be in our second line yeah right in the
neck all right all right he's got it I
gotta figure it out it's locked in one
shot one kill
maybe I'm jinxing it probably okay this
guy's on the movies a little tricky 250
meters we're still going on second dog
you got to get it through the Porta
Potty oh no hang on through the Porta
Potty
can i I see that dude we're doing so
well we I gotta do the Porta Potty
though is great yeah like that alright
we're gonna give him a fourth try cuz
we're we're generous and we will do a
bonus try hopefully we get through this
mission now they'll probably be the end
of the stream what sounds about right
just to pimp some other stuff remember
at two o'clock titanfall two newest DLC
a glitch in the frontier Robin Mike will
be streaming that two o'clock today that
isn't about an hour and 45 minutes
hopefully we're waiting for it to you
actually it'll do it yeah and then
tomorrow we got lobby of course at 11
a.m. also we're going to be playing some
Call of Duty some of the older world war
games at 9:00 a.m. Pacific so we want to
join for that cool also our review of
burger threes up on GameSpot mm-hm that
got a 5 out of 10 for this game diver go
check it out yep crazy I have a 99 we
don't have a sub button on Twitch
because we don't want to no no I thought
you were one shot one kill guy guy
all right we do have a sub button on
YouTube but that's a different sub
button obviously the guys gave me the
most trouble is that dude by the Porta
Potty uh John I believe you can change
the difficulty during your playthrough
because that's what I yeah I just yeah
so he's at 270 will you play Cod too
probably
I haven't worked out all the details in
terms of what games they're playing but
I wouldn't be shocked maybe we just go
center-mass make our lives easier
yep right in the shoulder no problem I
think I was going for the headshots and
that was my problem no but you can't go
for that show like this dude kept
alerting when I killed the other guy
yeah we're gonna have to kill him both
this dude was he the guy giving us the
trouble or is there another guy no that
was the guy oh no that was the guy you
killed through the corner potty we're
gonna wait over the guy Yoda wait wanted
250 we're at second line okay alright
right in the shoulder he's like thanks
bud cover me okay third guy so I can't
miss this one because these two dudes
oh thanks I've been sorry that you can't
shower us with your money but you
watching is enough I I'm not entirely
sure how many kills Jesus you could have
shot through that you're pro propwash
you could have sniped do an earthquake
no problem all right nope nope this dude
here okay know what about the guy that's
going into the door Aaron what's his
range
250 300 meters Jim in the butt nope oh
yeah he's safe he's safe oh wait no nope
nope they're alerted oh right in the
thigh there's two guys here oh canister
did nothing Oh
why doesn't that easy what did my agent
suck so bad at staying alive it's your
job to give him covered man he's just an
infiltrator he expect him to be a
warrior he's a ghost he's got all his
points back to in the ghost tree that's
what happens when you speck in a guest
you don't play warrior enough you wanna
give it one more go yeah okay you get
one last this is its final chance here
final chance what did I do wrong there I
you stop sniping people after the
helicopter showed up I so he ran in so I
guess it must be also timed okay uh
because like what triggered what
triggered them sweet hand know you got
checkpoint cool checkpoint
okay let's take care of this dish just
wasn't your miss that caused them to
agro though shoot you yeah no I bet hey
I'll give you a dollar if you are too
late it's just a time I was gonna say if
you could nail that guy while the
helicopter was flying by I would've gave
you a dollar but uh how are you gonna
kill these two guys he's cuz your guys
moving up I don't know what's the plan
dude I think you gotta take them both
out right or at least one of them so
that he can at least kill the other guy
yeah
I'm assuming that's the plan or worried
he's gonna go around oh oh he's gonna
get the flake what's plan I think he's
waiting for you to kill him no this is
gonna be a double kill you're gonna team
kill maybe you can want it get them both
Bend the bullet baby do you expect me to
do this for you what kind of warrior are
you okay whoa gab we're playing on the
hardest difficulty with no HUD do it I'd
like to see you snipe okay telling me to
kill it this guy so dope are you gonna
step in front have an argument come on
come together yeah who do you want to
bet on come together right now over me
have a fight well is the target that is
that what you're setting up for him to
shoot or is that just who you're lined
up on this guy is not communicating well
with me I think you can take your chain
all right here we go take the guy with
the target over his head
Oh what happened what was that noise Oh
see your other do you took him out who
then yeah to the Dix AUSA spotting me
what what he's most range he's engaged
in close range who's engaging vehicles
right no no no not you your agent yeah
well he died all the other times no oh
there's an exploder than what I can't
see you who are you shooting at
maybe he's fine talk I know he's good
no we're gonna cover the age yeah right
exfiltrate get out of there I think that
uh remember right from the e3 demo that
high-end helicopter comes back after you
filtrate guys everybody filtrate we did
it no problem I can't fast travel
alright he didn't shoot both excuse me
he shot one guy and then the agent took
out the other guy once we shot the
finally every other time that guy was
like uh I want to do this gun he's like
he's good when he's on a flank I told
you he's all ghosts man he's you know he
sneaks up and finishes
you know the job that's there for all
right Aaron good job
proud of you wait a way to make it
through there yeah that only took me
many tries yeah so what are your general
kind of thoughts after playing you know
kind of the first two areas a bit add I
call these types of games incredibly
adequate games they'll get the job done
if you like sniping games there is
plenty of sniping as pointing it out in
our review you know mission objectives
are varied like I think you can
definitely get your sort of Far Cry 2
style and driven out of this game
there's a lot of tooling around and your
buggy and killing wolves and finding
drones and investigating tragedies the
load times I didn't think we're that big
of a deal even though they were about
five minutes to get a new match just
because I don't know you can just turn
it on to kind of go do some other stuff
he's the bathroom setter
yo yeah you can check out the review on
GameSpot five out of ten it is
considered mediocre on our scale but
yeah thank you guys for tuning in and
don't forget at two o'clock in about an
hour and a half we got another
livestream with Robin Mike for titanfall
to their new DLC a glitch in the
frontier but otherwise thanks Aaron
thanks for watching and thanks everybody
for watching and commenting with us see
you later